continuing our coverage of the 2020
scouting combine in indianapolis joining
us now the brand new head coach of the
carolina panthers he is matt rule and i
say brand new
it's been several weeks it probably
already seems like you've been on the
job for a long time it does it feel it
it really feels like years and uh but in
a good way you know um we've just gotten
a lot done and uh you know you take one
of these jobs you show up and you're
excited and then it's just kind of get
to work and start just slowly
methodically making sure you're ready so
i think we've made a lot of progress
before where does it start like just
kind of take us through the first week
of the head coach of the carolina
panthers how do you kind of digest it
and go through it all i think there's
really two things you want to make sure
you get to the key players right and
introduce yourself and you know because
anytime you have a new coach there's
going to be a little bit of like hey
what's this about who's this guy going
to be um and then hiring a staff and as
you know in the nfl level guys are under
contract it's really a process to
navigate so trying to make sure that you
know you're there and present for the
players on the team you know if they
call you reach out to you or if you can
reach out to them and then hiring a
really good staff as well right what
surprised you the most so far about this
job
um
you know i think as a college coach i
dealt so much of my day was dealt with
was you know so-and-so missed class so
and so was five minutes late and so you
show up and there's really no players
there so you know and that's what i love
i love being around players i think
great coaches make their you know help
their players play better and so um
there's a few chances i have to be
around our guys when they come in for
treatment or i've really enjoyed that so
i'm really looking forward to the off
season and you know the voluntary phases
of the guys working out so i can just
kind of be around and be a coach because
that's what i love to do yeah it's the
most positive possible spin that i've
ever heard a coach put on the limited
access to players
in the off season john gruden two years
ago when he got back in the game and the
rules had changed it was borderline
profanity after profanity about not
having access but he's coming that's a
good way to put it well he's happy where
it's even less less access to coaching
guys so yeah i get it you probably feel
like wow i can really coach here yeah
once they're allowed to show up yeah
once they're all right um all right
let's just get to right to it i mean you
know i know you're gonna answer this
question nine million times so cam
newton you know i mean i know you're not
guaranteeing he's a starter if healthy
or whatever that may be how much tape
have you watched do you watch you know
for you to get a good feel for where
he's at in his career yeah i mean i've
watched not just for him but for the
entire team i've watched the offense
defensive special teams going all the
way back to like 2015 you know 2016 and
i think that's really important just to
see like what does it mean when you know
when carolina has one what does how do
they win what is what is the atmosphere
like right just in every way so um but i
i guess the big thing for me is i'm
really excited to coach cam newton like
you know just getting to know him being
around him seeing the way that he's
rehab and the way he's taken this
seriously um i think i think if he does
this right and we do this right now his
best football's ahead of him and so um
you know i didn't know him before coming
there and i've really enjoyed my
interactions with him and so you know i
have a job to do and it's not to start
talking about like six months from now
it's about right now making sure that we
get cam healthy for this fall because if
he's healthy there's really no questions
about who he is or what he can do so
just making sure that that's really our
focus right now getting that in place
but i felt like coming here i wanted to
make sure people knew like i i really
want to coach this guy i really like
this guy and um i really like the way
he's approaching his rehab and the way
he's doing things anything just real
quick like specifically like on film
when you watch camden maybe that you did
or didn't know or something he does
better than you expected well i think um
i think two things i'd say number one
off the field when you talk to other
players like there's such a deep deep
deep respect for him in the locker room
for the what he does in between the
white lines and the way he'll play no
matter what right and then i think you
go back and look at him on third now you
look at the ability for him to throw the
ball you know even last year playing on
her foot he's throwing 18-yard comebacks
to the right sideline so uh he coming
off that shoulder he still he still got
the arm right and so to me it's a matter
of us putting in a new system it's going
to be a little bit different for him but
i think whether it's him or will or kyle
or anybody else i think it's a really
good quarterback friendly system right
at your introductory press conference
owner david tupper was asked about cam
newton and he pivoted to this concept of
the importance of buying in and
obviously it's critical for your
starting quarterback to buy in
how hard is it to sell him on sticking
around and buying in when he's had one
head coach's entire nfl career feels
like everything around him is changing
what kind of a challenge is that and how
how much have you been allowed to talk
to him about that to kind of get a feel
for whether or not he is all in with
what you're trying to do yeah i haven't
really had to talk about that i mean um
i i think i think uh and really for the
with all the players i mean i think for
me i have to come in and say hey this is
what we're gonna do and just start
moving forward and and um
i haven't sensed any of that i think a
lot of guys are excited about what we're
going to do i think you know obviously
some of them have been here for for many
years are proud of what they've done but
you know we all understand things change
and it's it's a new year and so i don't
care if you won the super bowl last year
or if you're if you lost last year had a
tough year it's all about you know the
next season so i think guys are excited
about what we're doing downstairs and
you know in the weight room training
room some of the sports science things
we're bringing in and um you know
that's really that to me that's the
buy-in it shows it'll show up in the
off-season it'll show up in training
camp camping in the season and um i have
no reason to doubt the guys won't be
bought into what we're doing is there
any coaches you know you've been around
the nfl and of course made a name for
yourself in college any coaches you've
sought advice from here throughout this
process that you've talked to to kind of
take on this this new challenge for you
yeah you know tom coughlin right off the
bat you know dick vermeel uh was someone
who reached out to me right away even in
the early process talking to uh
coach parcells you know so some of those
legendary great coaches who who have
always been gracious with their time for
me and and that after that really i mean
you know i saw andy reid this morning
know who i've known a long time saw
bruce arians who we were both temple
coaches and and i think all those guys
have been really supportive um sean
payton and i've had questions i've
called sean we're in the same you know
same division and he is i think there's
kind of a a really good uh brotherhood
of coaches that are out there and guys
been really good to me you've got some
experience coaching in the nfl with the
giants as an offensive line coach more
experience in college but
is there a fundamental difference
between college and pro players from the
standpoint of how you communicate with
them how you get them to respond how you
get them to do the things that you need
them to do to buy in to win i think it's
different for every coach you know i
think if you're a yeller and a screamer
all the time that you know i i always
try to think of everything whether i'm
in college or the pros it's not about
players and coaches it's just about
people and so everyone has different
things that they're going through
everyone has different issues and so um
you know when you're coaching in college
people sometimes forget that you have
125 players right so 125 guys with hopes
and dreams and you know if they have a
bad year they're still coming back the
next year um you know they all have the
same scholarship and so that's that's
one set of things you come to the nfl
level you know
you have you know a 53-man roster you
know so it's cut down in half and some
guys are at the end of their career they
just want to hold on for a little longer
some guys are just getting started so i
just think when you identify it as
what's my job as a coach my job is to
make sure that i'm helping my players
play better if we really do that and
we're just not saying that i always felt
like players respond to coaches who
helped them play better and so
um we're going to try to do that at this
level you know when i was an assistant i
thought it worked i've got a bunch of
really good teachers and coaches with
not a lot of egos and i i think our
staff will will really have a lot of
buy-in from the players in terms of how
we do stuff yeah uh i mean
you made a name for yourself because of
your team building i mean you took over
a tough spot in temple and made them
relevant and baylor i thought like oh
they're done forever when our prize and
the scandal hit and you save them all of
a sudden i'm going what they're in the
big 12 championship game this year
what is the difference between building
a winner in college and and then the nfl
in your opinion or if there is a
difference or an easier or harder
whatever it may be i think obviously in
college you do it through recruiting and
through development i think here there's
there's such a different you know when
it comes to free agency in the draft so
it's a different means to the same end
yeah but you know i think the good thing
for me is because i've been a part of
both of those i mean i did a lot of good
when i say i mean my staff we did a lot
of good things and we did a lot of
things that i wouldn't do again i was a
much better head coach of baylor than i
was at temple and so as i come into this
new challenge
i have a lot of experience to pull from
that i say hey this work this didn't
work and i told guys all along the way i
don't see here and pretend like i have
it all figured out you know i'm gonna
make mistakes as a head coach but i
think the thing that i just never wanted
to be about me and i hope players
respond to that and we have a good
nucleus of veteran players in carolina
who who i think are going to be great to
work with and help me as i transition
we've got one of the best offensive
weapons in football and christian
mccaffrey what should we expect it's
fans of the game from him this year is
your philosophy going to be let's just
let use them till the wheels come off or
you're going to be a little more
cautious to get into the fourth year of
his career and at some point there's
only so many hits you can take before
the wheels do come off just give us a
sense of what that that that approach
will be to using a guy who was uh about
the third member of the thousand-yard
rushing thousand-yard receiving club
well i think he you know christian's a
dynamic player and i you know i don't
think there's many people in football
who take care of themselves as way as
christian as well as christian does i
mean he goes above and beyond in the
season out of season to make sure that
he's healthy and can keep answering the
bell and so i'm excited about those
things i think you know we want to
continue to expound upon all the skill
sets that he has i mean there's not many
guys who can line up and you know run i
formation power
run zone read and then oh by the way
they can go out in the slot yeah so i
think when you know we hired joe brady
we hired a really good offensive staff
of guys that are creative and um without
giving probably too much away we'd like
to do a lot of different things with
christian to to to allow him to just be
as dynamic as possible and get them in
the open field and also you know we have
curtis samuel and dj moore and we have a
plethora of backs that we feel really
good about who haven't played a ton but
we feel good about so i think we're
going to try to open the whole thing up
and use everybody
um do you feel like you have an
advantage you know compared to some of
these coaches because you've been in
college like you've seen some of these
kids in person is do you feel that way
or am i wrong to think that well i think
i have a lot of history with a lot of
these guys you know i think um i think
you know like i said there's ten guys
here that you know four that i coached
at temple six i coached at baylor so i
maybe some insight on those guys but
then a lot of guys i played against
walking down the hallways and i you know
i see sidney lam or jaylen reagar i mean
i've seen those guys up close and
personal right so i think i have a feel
for them and then you know as i go
around college you know pro days and
stuff like there's a lot of guys on
those staffs who i know i've worked with
so i think i have a good feel for that
but you know that that that that the
advantage is only good if you if you use
it properly
take advantage of it so but i think um
you know we're always going to try to
gain as much information as possible and
hopefully we come in with a little bit
from coming from college yeah free
agency is going to be the closest thing
to college recruiting it starts within a
few weeks what is your role what is your
voice in the process of deciding which
players to go out and pursue in free
agency i you know i
marty hearn is still the gm but it's
still this new era this new regime and
and how does how does your voice fit
into that process of selecting who will
be i think new panthers yeah i think
marty would tell you that you know every
great gm you know they they build a team
but they don't want to bring they don't
want to bring a coach a player he
doesn't want to coach and so you know
what we've tried to do is we've sat
there and and the scouting staff has
taught the coaches hey this is our
process but then the coaches have sat
there with the staff and scouting staff
said hey this is what we're looking for
in a quarterback and this is what we're
looking for in a three technique and
showing them on video and showing them
examples because what we're trying to do
is take all these different people and
align them so we see things the same way
and so um i think that that's really
going to be an advantage for us you know
when you're a college coach
you do a lot of personnel you do a lot
of evaluations you do a lot of
projections and so
i come by that naturally now to have a
guy with marty's experience um all he
wants to do is put a winner on the field
and all marty wants to do is make sure
that we have players that we want to
coach and so i it's been an unbelievable
relationship so far and so i think that
extends into free agency you know
the one difference between college and
pro is they're not all the same
scholarship guys get different amounts
of money so for us it's about us finding
guys with the traits that we want that
makes sense for us you know for this
year and beyond we've done great things
as a coach it's going to be fun to see
how it all plays out for the carolina
panthers starting this september coach
thanks for your time congratulations on
all the best moving forward appreciate
you guys good luck
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports